hey leute was genau im netz bekommen zu
einem neuen video ich habe ja vor zehn
bis zwölf tagen oder so dies eine video
gemacht hat weil der zugriff jetzt nicht
so weiterlaufen wird wie es halt immer
war und dass sich alle erst mal so einen
kleinen abstand von youtube brauche ich
habe jetzt gedacht nach dieser zeit ja
komm ich habe megawatt weiter videos zu
machen und ich hatte auch nie vor auf 10
oder so auf jeden fall gibt es etwas was
euch ein bisschen angeht was ich sagen
muss vielleicht es gibt schon sehr viele
spekulationen was mich ehrlich gesagt
ziemlich aufgeregt wenn ihr dann unter
jedes bild eure vermutung schreibt also
ja es ist jetzt also ich bin nicht mehr
mit meiner freundin zusammen wie das
sich jetzt weiter entwickelt kann ich
sagen also ist jetzt halt erst mal so es
ist besser für uns beide wir haben uns
vernünftig getrennt gleiche mahl wir mal
ab und zu noch kontakt also ist jetzt
sagen so wahnsinnig auch daraus erfreut
schon irgendwie kann ich sagen keine
ahnung aber wir haben es jetzt erstmal
für uns entschieden
es wäre es unfair irgendeine seite da
genauer zu darüber zu reden und ich habe
auch keine lust dass ihr zu ihr hingeht
und unter ihre fotos schreibt ja du bist
voll scheiße warum hast du das gemacht
warum sollte ich mir zusammen also das
hat ihr keinen fall verdient dies ein
ganz liebes mädchen und das wollte ich
auf jeden fall noch sagen also vergesst
das nicht
und bitte hört auch in zukunft damit auf
meine videos oder irgendwas damit zu
kommentieren wie schade dass auch ist
und blablabla dann bringen wir auch
bilden die saat in dieser situation
überhaupt nichts und ich hoffe ihr
versteht nicht da fans mega geil dass es
3000 15.000 menschen gibt die mich so
nehmen wie ich bin
ich habe letztens schon gesagt ich hoffe
ihr bleibt mir weiter treu ob jetzt mit
ihr zusammen bin oder nicht
ob jetzt mich abonniert hat bei den
video mit von uns beiden gesehen aber
nicht lasst euch mal überrascht was in
zukunft kommt es wird auf jeden fall
sehr geil es wird viele kollaborations
mit anderen usern geben in den nächsten
wochen und ich mache auf samstag in ein
neues video danach die woche kommt auch
in der woche ein video und sonst
also das war geil ich freue mich auf das
jahr und wir sehen uns am samstag wieder
ansonsten würde ich sagen ich hoffe ihr
versteht das
und jetzt kommt auch noch die sonne raus
passgenau und hotline leute